je suis mme olivier bonjour merci d'être
en direct sur arte france alors
l'allemagne et la france qui ont donc
annoncé dans un communiqué commun un
assouplissement des restrictions de
circulation entre les deux pays quelle
est la signification politique de ce
communiqué selon vous mais je crois
qu'on avait tout à fait conscience du
côté allemand qu'il y avait une certaine
impatience
maintenant du côté penser parce que le
bouclage de la frontière entre les deux
pays à la hauteur si vous voulez de la
chasse lorraine et de du bade wurtemberg
a été extrêmement importante le nombre
de loups lieu de passage ont été réduit
très fortement
si bien que cela a considérablement le
compliquer la vie des gens en
particulier des travailleurs frontaliers
et qui vont dans l'autre pays pour
travailler reviennent le soir 6 et quand
c'était très compliqué on il ya
également de gros problèmes concernant
les couples franco-allemands mixte non
mariés pour se rendre visite
les exigences les autorités allemandes
étaient extrêmement élevé donc il y as
eu ce besoin si vous voulez et oga
également pour des raisons purement
économiques
par exemple les députés des députés
ouest-allemand des régions frontalières
bade wurtemberg ça et rhénanie palatinat
ont demandé au gouvernement d'assouplir
de file et les mesures de contrôle de
façon à ce que des relations économiques
et sociales plus normale puisse se
rétablir en tenant compte bien sûr de la
situation épidémiologique de part et
d'autre alors une attestation unique
franco allemande sera désormais mises en
place dans les prochains jours pour les
parents ou encore les visites dans les
ehpad est ce qu on a une idée du nombre
de personnes concernées
je crois que non je crois qu'on ne sait
pas encore exactement combien de
personnes cela va seulement concerné
mais pour une raison si vous voulez très
simple c'est qu'il ya quand même
énormément de relations entre les
personnes vivant de part et d'autre de
la frontière
donc ce sera et on ne sait pas
exactement aussi les quelles seront
exactement les mêmes et les mesures qui
vont être exigé les textes du ministre
de l'intérieur monsieur faisait ofer est
relativement imprécis justement pour ne
pas se laisser enfermer sans doute dans
des obligations est trop pressante
tant qu'il sera au fur et à mesure que
les mesures vont être appliquées qu on
va voir ce qu'est ce qui est
véritablement est autorisée
naturellement d'allemagne se réserve le
droit de pouvoir de nouveau introduire
des mesures de contrôle plus sévère si
jamais le virus se développe de nouveaux
une partie de la frontière
alors la france l allemagne visant
retour à une circulation libre en europe
à partir de mi juin est ce que
l'objectif visé par le couple
franco-allemand de relancer l'économie
vous avez affirmé évidemment que c'était
un des objectifs est ce qu'il ya à
d'autres oui à la liberté d'une personne
c'est quand même au delà qui tout à fait
tout à fait fondamental de l'union
européenne l'esprit chine où les de
schengen laure d'abord qu'il faut ouvrir
les frontières intérieures
ça se faire peu à peu denses et les
jours qui viennent ce sera avec le
luxembourg il ya eu de gros problèmes
entre l'allemagne et le luxembourg avec
la belgique et la hollande
les frontières sont troubles r très
prochainement ce week-end en principe ce
sera avec le avec le dac mc
il ya également une détente qui se
produit à la frontière entre l'allemagne
et l'autriche
donc on voit que concernant les pays de
l'europe de l'ouest la détente s'amorce
après il restera le problème des
rapports avec avait avec la pologne
et puis deuxième défilé difficulté
suivant ce sera de savoir si nous sommes
en mesure de nous entendre pour ouvrir
les frontières extérieures de l'union de
l'union européenne et on voit très bien
qu'il ya deux approches actuellement au
sein de l'union européenne
la tendance générale c'est de dire il
faut essayer si vous voulez de
coordonnées mais surtout il faut qu'il y
ait des accords bilatéraux
franco-allemand autres la france et
différents pays
l'italie est contre cette approche parce
que elle craint d'être discriminés elle
préférerait qu'il y ait un accord
véritablement européenne sont de
coordination au niveau européen de façon
à ce qu'elle ne soit pas laisser de côté
les pays méditerranéens sont assez
inquiets agisse de l'italie de l'espagne
du portugal parce que ce sont des pays
qui reçoivent énormément de touristes
le tourisme représente une part
importante de leur produit intérieur
brut
donc leur intérêt c'est que des choses
se stabilisent le plus rapidement
possible henri menuisier spécialiste des
relations franco allemandes merci
d'avoir répondu à nos questions